thank you now I have a new tool to
progress my slide hope it'll work oops
so my topic is vision what is the vision
vision is here's a scene and we have a
device called camera and we take data
called images and then what the vision
does is from image to figure out what
the scene is now it sounds as simple but
obviously it's very difficult problem as
you see here guessing the reality from
projection is pretty tough problem now
computer vision is indeed one of the
earliest problems in artificial
intelligence as you may know it started
in blocks world hand I project and
vision program vision computer vision
has been tried from early on for with
the quite intensive effort but
nonetheless it turns out to be very
difficult and there's a very well-known
episode that Minsky said that vision
must be very simple you a graduate
student can solve as a summer project
and it turns out it's so difficult that
even after 40 or 50 more than 50 years
we are still working and I'm happy that
it has been solved because I made a
career on it by the way actually when I
when I asked the Marvin about this he
said he didn't mean that but anyway that
is a known episode oops it doesn't
now why is it difficult well the one is
the sheer number even the vga video
produced 20 megabytes per second when it
comes to high-definition TV 160
megabytes per second so we have to
process this much data indeed it is
often said when compared with speech
vision is two dimensional we have a lot
of data and so forth and that's true
even though I'm not sure that the sheer
number is that a difficult oops then now
as to the number there's an interesting
fact simple fact I say a large unit
consists of a large number of small
images now learning is very popular
today so if you're shown one
high-definition TV image two thousand
pixel x 1000 pixels then in it oops in
it now I have a habit of showing the
vc's ah in it there's a 10 by 10 image
here and the next and so forth so there
are two file actually 1090 positions
this way on 990 so in total we have we
must have seen roughly 2 million ten by
ten sub-images given one high-definition
TV so by just seeing 11 image you must
have learned two million ten by ten
images that's a lot of learning but
there's another simple fact I say that
is let's ask how many 10 by 10 images
exist now imagine one pixel is made of
8-bit black and white pixel not even a
color 8-bit so 256 different image of
one pixel image so if it's 10 by 10 then
200 power of 10 by 10
which is 210 of 240 but let me prove how
big this number is this number is far
bigger than this very important number
for human gain which is imagined for
safety human being has been was born 1
million years ago maybe little later but
say just for safety 1 million years ago
and even they won imagine 10 billion
people are living on the earth probably
only 500 people at that time that's my
guess and imagine they are individually
watching every day every hour every
minute every second 30 frames per second
high-definition TV each of each each of
them is watching different Channel not
the same channel different Channel and
in total human being must have learned
10 of 31 that's far far smaller than 10
to 240 now you might say no the world
with China there are many more people
maybe so oh well let's make it 11 you
may say no human eye is not 2000 by 1000
it's worth of one medium pixel x 1
million pixel maybe so that will
increase this number 12 but thats that
doesn't make this number nowhere near
240 so i have proven very important
point which is humankind has not yet all
of ten by ten seeing all of 10 by 10
images i call it canada's theorem by the
way i have never seen anybody yet who
could refute by theorem so i believe
this has been proven so this means that
this implies that we need actually a
fairly bold assumptions to solve any
vision problem so that is actually the
meaning in my
fine the sheer why doesn't ok number
aspect but why vision is really
difficult is actually more than that one
is 2d 3d degeneracy image is a
projection so 3 dementia ward is
degenerated so basically we're asked you
know 2 times 0 is 0 what was the
original number it's impossible in a
sense in a sense and while you may say
that well from this for example this one
the world is 3d picture is to thee from
2d we ask which of these buildings a
father now we may say it's obvious this
building is father and we ask why
because that building looks smaller
nothing wrong to have a small building
in front of a big building you may say
oh no this building is including this up
building nothing wrong to build inverse
l-shaped building is built so actually
this inverting projection is
theoretically obviously impossible now
another difficulty is present world is
single compounders pixel value is the
result of compounded physical phenomena
for example this pixel from you is this
is dark that is because the of this
cloth is dark this is wider than here
that is not because the cloth is wider
but because more light is on and as a
picture you can't tell which was the
reason somehow we should be able to
recover that and that is obviously a
very tough question
context which is artificial intelligence
favorite topic when you ask what is this
and then said he will say car now you
ask why is this car people call say
because it's on the road now in this
obviously the context is playing a big
role because if you remove all of the
context this is the thing it doesn't
look like a car and for sure oops for
sure this is this context which is the
road is making that small thing appear
as a car but if you ask then why is this
a road that most people say because
there's a car on it and well that
doesn't help us to solve the problem so
that is the kind of problem that we
should we should discuss we should
attack oh this is not hate this and so
in summary computer lesions fundamental
difficulty part from a sheer number is
this cyclic dilemma in one too many
problem as I said from projection
recover reality is one too many problem
and in that we have many chicken and egg
cyclus cyclic problem such as distance
once we know the size the real size of
the object of course the appearance will
help you to know the distance but if you
don't know both neither then we have a
cliq dilemma so is the case of occlusion
for example if we know we know my hand
is ACLU's my face but in order to do
that know that you probably have to know
this is my face otherwise you cannot
tell this is not part of the face so
that is and another thing is manual
coding in early on the typical approach
in computer vision was what I named
let's program what I think I'm doing
when he never given a picture we thought
oh what is the pic what is tree and they
say Oh pic tree is green thing on top of
brown thing so we wrote the program what
I call let's program what I think I'm
doing approach and everything was like
that but unfortunately we each of us is
a vision expert but does not know how
we're doing it so that approach didn't
work as well as we thought search
explosion is essentially when we turn
the cyclic dilemma to a search problem
which we should then the search tenth
explode very quickly and computer
computers have been too slow for that
and a very important thing which I think
people have forgotten early on in
artificial intelligence is the lack of
understanding how to use physics in
vision I think the physics has been
neglected for a long time is part of the
fact that physical process optics
geometry etc and noise is indeed
dominating how the picture is taken and
so that those are the reason why the
problem was so difficult and nonetheless
I think we have made some progress and I
like to go over a little bit of progress
by using only my and my CMU colleagues
work sorry if I don't use your work
because I'm not I couldn't collect all
of the example but I collected example
from our own work so let's go with that
so face recognition for ego this is my
PhD thesis 40 years ago and today it
seems that my own usual joke doesn't
work i think when i give a talk and
always they say probably none of you
were even born when I wrote the PhD here
it seems that many of you were born or
even before me so it doesn't work but
anyway 40 years ago this is my pieces
and can you tell it's interesting 40
years ago when we process one image
successfully by our program we could
write a paper and it passed and we
process 10 images we proudly said with a
large-scale experiment comma we shown we
have shown XYZ now at that time the one
of the most one of the proudest thing I
had was this program was actually tested
with 1000 images at that time and but
nonetheless it's only 33 people about
75% of recognition rate but since then
myself actually other people have done
the quite a bit of phase this is our
work detection which we use every day
now on your cell phone and camera and
this is 1996 98 great time and actually
it's pretty good today this is very
common and if you look at it of course
detective we say face detection
precisely speaking this should be called
face image detection because obviously
this is not face see this is face image
my program does not know that so it's
probably detect that as a face and know
that as not a not a face but a face
picture is of course pretty difficult
task and today the more difficult and
common problem is called alignment that
is actually no individual component in
the picture and we have done some
program made some progress and the
program is actually available online if
you send a picture picture we process
and you'll get there back
and it works pretty well and I think a
Chinese student sent in a very beautiful
picture is so cendien have a Japanese
person obviously a very meticulous he
wanted to have what i call stress test
of our program and this is what these
guys sent like this and it took two
hours to process this image for about
500 actually this picture is much bigger
than this and it's successfully could do
that and then then of course in real
world it's actually interesting many
people have do extreme expression and
this kind of program uses so-called
knowledge how the face you know they are
the parts line and so forth and position
relationship size of relationship and so
forth and these example really violates
some of the very common ratio for
example this guy the distance from here
to here here to here is usually about
the same from here this guy is about
twice as big as this one so it's not
easy because if you allow them to be a
legitimate face then then a lot of faces
which are not legitimate well now
recognized as a face so you have to deal
with that problem correctly to de
finally I think we have a pretty good
alignment program which which actually
does precise all posts all polls
three-dimensional and occlusion robust
in the sense that all of the occlusion
and not only that the result I think I'm
very proud of it because it's it's just
like almost ham generated and more than
that it actually knows the occlusion so
when you do this this program actually
doesn't out
put this portion because program knows
this is not a phase this part is not a
phase program knows this part is not a
face and so forth program knows this
part is not a phase therefore it doesn't
try to output eyes and so forth so I
think the occlusion is in this simple
example is we are getting handle on it
and face recognition today is actually
amazing and if you look at this progress
last five or so years actually human
recognition rate given this type of
image which is full image face itself
and background is about 99.2 I think
computers are actually getting there and
if this rate is the case then you see
within a one or two here this great will
surpass the human and that's where we
have today and I think it's getting oops
will you go back yeah so face
application everywhere today camera cell
phones internet security and as I said
computer Facebook mission is as good as
humans and indeed if for most serious
applications human performance computer
performance is actually better than
human for example given a database of
1.6 million mugshot recognition rate is
as good as 95% you cannot do it because
we cannot look at 1.5 sickening six
million people let alone even hundred
people i'm not sure if we can do it
correctly so face is pretty under
control and more is coming and this is
one of the problem that we have because
which call obama speaks Japanese and we
create Obama's face which is easy movie
industry does that all the time but the
point is that input is down lately
passively by instead since without it
bring any dots more you guys don't care
what I think we can do it you know I'm
saying the computer face recognition is
difficult you don't nobody machina see
giorgio maggiore Barnabas endorses ja ja
ja statement look all the time thanks
for him the next topic I'd like to talk
a little bit about is multi camera
vision 20 years ago 19 early 1990s I
started a multi-camera research and I
had a strong conviction that the stereo
should use more than two cameras in
spite of the fact that human has only
two eyes I think that his accident I
think we should have had more eyes
that's my strong belief so he started
two three four and and so forth and then
we built 1992 five camera system 256 x
250 i ate depth depth image in 30 frames
per second that was one of the earliest
machine which amazingly consumed 5000
what 5,000 it's hot actually when we
turn on the whole room do you need any
the heater it was so hot and then we
built 51 camera system here circa
nineteen ninety-five at that time we
didn't have enough bandwidth to take all
the 51 cameras input into computer in
real time so we did what we did is we
bought 51 VCR video tape recorders and
the corner and all these cameras were
synchronized and time coded each frame
and after the experiment we took video
out and put it in the digitizer another
one digitizer and because each frame is
time coded we know which frame on this
tape corresponds to which paper risk but
can you tell I can tell you when you
have 51 VCRs even doing the experiment
is very deftly off because when you
start you have to push 51 start buttons
my students complained professor your
robotics professor please develop robots
to push the button I said no and he's
asked why I said because students are a
lot cheaper than robots so anyway that's
this story on that by the way I had a
strong conviction the large number of
cameras is coming when we wrote a paper
on the five stereo camera it was
rejected and the reason was this camera
which uses five this stereo system which
uses five cameras will never be used in
the world because it's so expensive that
was the rejection and it says this is
this can be built only by takeo canara
who has so much research money but not
not in real world
that's this is true story indeed that
was the rejection letter that I received
and because it's so funny that the world
changes so quickly and then from that
inside of that dome the what happens can
be digitized I call for d digitization
because X Y Z T and once its disguise
you can actually synthetic court and you
can see the view from anywhere and based
on this one we did some system which is
named I vision by broadcaster CBS which
is used for Super Bowl broadcast in 9
2001 you know movie matrix I haven't
seen it myself but I was told he was you
know main character jumps and you can
see around spin around him that is made
this way all these dots are cameras and
in at the center which all these camera
focus the actor performs and at the
right timing all the cameras take
picture at the same time and they are
concatenated as a result you think as if
the time is frozen you're spinning
around it so the idea is to do the same
with the football field but the football
fees large and of course you can't tell
where the interesting thing will occur
therefore each camera is replaced by
robot camera which actually track the
particular point and this is what we got
will you play now during today's
coverage of Super Bowl 35 CBS Sports
will introduce a new technology called I
vision
it provides panoramic coverage similar
to the amount of effects in there if a
matrix broadcasting I met him he's very
nice guy robotic cameras have been born
the upper deck camera seven degrees each
camera feeds and these are actually
storage today probably the see images
are the computer calibrated I'm just
sent eight assists show any spot on the
plane to DC from all angles within the
cameras 220 degree rain this Illuminati
of carnegie-mellon with design house
where the blends 30 cameras into one
dynamic panorama this is a gigantic
robotic system you have to have perfect
idea of the direction position of the
cameras and the relationship of the
amount of zoom amount of focus to the
command that you give from the computer
and that is one of the hardest job
here it is this is an example during the
warm ups taking just a moment ago the
pass from banks to Davis look at the
wake and whip around we're all looking
forward to it by the way it can be used
in instant replay situations into the
case of a challenge
if you're wondering what it is this is
what it was her this is how it works
quarterback he drops back look he sees a
big leg look at that big lane so he
steps up into it
site one string guilford nice look off
looks to his left and no
get that nicely he can see the receiver
down the field
yeah so I usually say that I'm the only
professor that has ever appeared on
Super Bowl there's a lot of story behind
this now so today multi camera
technology are used in everywhere indeed
our system was 51 camera system the
Super Bowl was 33 camera system there
are 200 500 there are a lot of them
today and entertainment as you know
camera multi camera system that will
allow you to get the picture everywhere
in focus camp picture and if you can
actually if you have a fall foliage for
which tree lines by having a
multi-camera you can actually see
through for some military applications
and surveillance we know that is common
and today actually we are actually
looking at even a larger number of
camera calibration this is the design
1000 camera system each dots in this
room a camera today we have actually 480
combined and with this certain
performance can be taken and digitized
and can be modeled I think the guy is
spreading the papers we can actually do
a lot of modeling of events inside see
so one of the things that we are looking
at is to use this kind of system to do
to study human communication so for
example we have we going the two rooms
we're going to have with High Definition
very high
display we are looking at about 8,000 by
six thousand display and you are here
and you think that you're talking with a
beautiful girl but actually you're
talking with me and this one is actually
synthesizing converting the reality and
so that I can control the timing the
manner that the person smile nas and see
how you change your reaction in other
word when you say I like him because he
agrees with me is it because he or she
looks actually agree with you or the way
you say the same thing we can change it
as we like and that the kind of thing
that we're looking at autonomous driving
30 years ago this is what we started it
was initially was about one centimeter
to second it's barely moving and this is
CMU's near and this is
ordinary when a child comes out car
stops and the story is that the guy does
the child is a son of the programmer who
coded to stop at the dangerous situation
and actually this system later 1995 so
it is what almost 20 years ago we
actually did no hands across came
America campaign 20 years ago so we
drove this 3,000 miles from Pittsburgh
to DC ninety-eight percent of which was
computer vision controlled 20 years ago
it was very interesting but not a
hundred percent so it's not usable today
if it's if it's not under percent indeed
we are sitting at the driver's seat and
holding not holding the steering wheel
like this just in case you can hold it
so actually it's more tiring than
driving yourself that's what we had
another interesting story that I have is
that we you know Jay Leno the famous
comedian he actually used this system
when this car was driving across America
he uses you know newspaper article as
the source of joke and he said here is
an article he said carnegie mellon
university's researcher developed
autonomous driving car which allows you
for the first time to take your hands
off the wheel and drink a coffee read
newspaper or makeup and he said why is
that world first in Los Angeles people
have been doing that forever
that was his joke so that was
interesting and we actually had fun now
today this is not 2007 this is our feels
with ludacris work with actual hello
girls fries this is complete--around
even able to hear long for safety is not
on the car it was very interesting that
the progress is relayed in about 12
wheels so today driving assistance is
with us autonomous driving is in sight
and the visualize lot more coming in a
sense of robot is getting the genuine
understanding of what is going on so far
or the program that has been developed
is very limited to understand the lane
where person or other car is not the
total understanding of the scene so I
think the carnegie mellon university's
researchers Munoz and Masha Allah bear
they were actually having a program
which given this road seen not only know
where to dry but also other things
scenery understanding which is indeed
the real sense of driving because by
that you can guess where the person
might come out or this is old this is a
child therefore it's more dangerous and
so forth possible case of change the
action and so forth and that is coming
and what we have today one of the things
that I'm interested in is new augmented
reality and I'm let me talk about this
for the last topic which we are doing
right now which called new augmented
reality that combines
nation projector and vision in one
device and enhanced vision human vision
so in a sense it's augmented reality but
it's not augment reality of what we tend
to hear that is you have a cell phone
and look at the thing and the cell phone
says oh this name of this building is
such and such it's called augmented
reality I call it no it's not all men
reality it is all augmented display of
reality reality is not augmented you see
this play is omitted what we are
interested in is augmenting the reality
so what does that really mean so in
driving this is rayne this is what you
get
the rain looks very white and blocks
your field of view it's annoying you
know why because the rain is raindrop
and the same is true with the snow are
highly reflective they act as a comp
convex lens and collect the light and
return that's why it looks white you
know in other word head light hits the
rain and returns so what we should do is
when rain comes look at where they are
and control the beam in such a way that
the beam will not hit the rain then you
should not see it okay now you may think
that's a serious silly but actually it's
not that difficult imagine your
projector and camera is placed at the
same place so your line the projectors
line of sight planetside means the
direction of the shooting the light is
the same as returning of the camera ok
so send a light very briefly take a
picture then the rain should become
white dots and imagine that we can take
we can process that image and know where
the rain dot is in the picture with zero
second delay time then what we should do
is turn off the projector so we change
now the headlight to projector basically
you know this that projector the same
projector turn off the beam that
corresponds to the dots
okay but actually takes a little time so
by the time we are ready probably the
raindrops will be a little lower yeah
therefore what you should do is turn on
the lights above it side safe this is
safe he is very safe very safe very safe
very safe almost safe almost now this
place is not maybe not as much because
the wind they make this this way so if
you shoot the light it may hit okay so
that's the strategy and indeed if you
look at take a picture with one
millisecond then rain for sure looks
like a dots because the rain is about 10
meter per second no faster than that
okay okay so as soon as you I got the
idea what you should do is we have
projector indeed that that projector the
same projector and the camera with the
half mirror and processor in between so
we modify the projector by the way
projector works most of the projector
about up to 60 frames a second that is
only because the need is that the
projectors the mirror the small mirror
goes as high as 2,000 frames per second
so we modify it so that it works and put
that in together with the camera with a
half mirror oh by the way the brightness
of the projector is about 4,000 lumen
which is even brighter than the
headlight of ordinary cars and we we
built our own headlight and put it
on a car oops put it on a car then you
see rain disappears
oops snow to my this is not real so no
this is snowflake and in a slow motion
you see it's easy in slow motion this is
about the speed that you have to deal
with in computer vision today is not a
difficult task so once we do that oops
that's really I hate this we go back
yeah I'm back I'm back yes we can think
of better easier one to which is up beam
low beam you see when you're driving
you're supposed to up him is easier to
drive but when the car comes you from
from you turn to the low beam because
the high beam will make you the driver
of the other side momentarily blind do
you know that period of momentarily
blindness takes longer for 55 years
older about five times longer eight
times longer than 16 years old so many
of you are in problem so what we should
do though is we don't need to turn to
the low beam all you have to do is to
turn off the beam which correspond to
your eye then you don't think it is a
high beam no let me see this is doesn't
work yeah so like this so this will make
always up beam headlight and indeed it
works on coming this is the others other
car it doesn't look like a high beam
this is your be your car it's always
high beam in fact
if you don't if you don't we turn on and
off the this is heidi see if we don't
make that capability if you turn off
that capability it looks like IBM but if
you turn on that capability it looks
like a low beam to you but that guy is
always high V okay so I think sorry I
actually designed to be about finished
in time but the rear view is the same
rear view when the guy come from behind
it's annoying so all I have to do is
turn off the beam which corresponds to
the rear view of the car in front of you
and then the guy in front of you can
actually see you clearly okay like this
but you always have you and if you have
turned actually combined with the radar
with a camera then detect a person in
the fog now this is tough one somehow we
have to let him that the person know
there's a person in the fog now showing
this doesn't help because then when you
drive you have to look at the display
that's that's more dangerous yeah you
have to look you have to it appears to
you that the person is visible now one
way is of course is to send obstacle our
spotlight but since it's a fog it may or
may not work so one possible idea is we
have actually more projectors on the car
and converge the beam so that that
particular position get the higher one
okay
now for that you need a bun you need a
baseline and the cars baseline which is
about 1.7 liter may or may not be enough
so we may have a hypo like this and then
we may be able to focus on the point or
eventual solution is put electrode on
you're here and the processed image will
be fed to you I then to your brain then
you'll see a person through the fog now
that's a futuristic idea and you may not
even it may or may not want that
solution but anyway so as you see this
is not augment reality of display this
is a real augmented reality so finally
sorry over on I think future various
points I think it's obvious your bigness
sensors low-power processes real-time
access internet and so forth will
actually bring us a new brands of
computer vision which is somewhat
different from traditional sense of
computer vision that's what I wanted to
say thank you very much